well there's two gaps there one is a gap
between ability to diagnose and cure and
there's other cases where we have the
ability to cure but not diagnose the
small set of people who will react very
negatively both of these I think are
going to see major progress there have
already seen some major progress but for
example different people have different
responses this is a personal decision if
you see some if you get diagnosed firs
if you are offered the ability to get
diagnosed for disease for which there is
no cure some people say I don't want to
know that other people will say I want
to know that but I'm not do anything
about it
and the third set say oh we're gonna
we're gonna embrace this we're going to
become experts on this disease even even
they're not even scientists they become
experts think of Lorenzo's oil where
Augusto donee actually starts to learn
biochemistry and and himself makes a
contribution to lipid disorders makes a
new drug like food like molecule but
there are many cases of this where
people will become the poster their
family will become poster children for
the disease Michael J Fox for
Parkinson's and Doug Melton for diabetes
and Betty Ford for cancer and substance
abuse and so forth
and so I think that's a really a big
opportunity is to take ownership of all
the things that are special about your
family both positive and negative and
link up with other families that have
the same alleles the same changes in
their DNA same variations to make them
different from the average and see how
it plays out differently in different
families you know maybe that some of
them have much more severe traits than
others and you can find by sharing that
information you can see what lifestyle
changes might be correlated with a less
severe outcome so I think that embracing
things that don't have cures whether
they're severe or not is an opportunity
that we'll see more
could certainly in that I would say in
the short term but since these are
exponential technologies it's actually a
very long time and say an internet time
okay
is that we will I think that most people
will get access to their genetic
information a lot of people will want it
and they will get it this will be a
it'll probably be affordable this year
so that's not you know that's not very
long even an internet time but then to
get an interpreter that you'll have to
share I don't know exactly how that work
out but I see trends towards sharing you
know Wikipedia you know the Red Cross
all kinds of things and old and new that
indicate that at least a significant
fraction of the population will share
their their genes their environment and
their traits and I also see that stem
cells where you can take a bit of skin
and reprogram it so then you can get
access to any tissue in your body that's
coming down just in a few years then
using that to fix what's going on in
adult aging so you actually stay
youthful for a longer period of time not
necessarily eliminating aging but
certainly increasing our that quality of
life I think that will happen and that
will have a huge impact because there's
a certain wisdom that will happen when
healthy people stay healthy and engaged
for a long period of time one of them
another one of the things that makes
humans fairly amazing is that they do
live for a long time well past what
would have been their reproductive limit
in ancient days because you know
grandparents and great-grandparents and
business leaders and so forth add value
that goes beyond the reproductive years
and I think that if we can make those
very healthy and very undistracted by by
health issues that would be a huge
change in the future and then if we have
computers robots humans acting all
acting as super computers and geniuses
we have a planet full of six billion
people with each with six billion
supercomputers then you can no longer
predict I mean that's a that's a fairly
rosy picture
um but at that point you don't know
where it goes